well I mean did you always dream of
being a writer
what was your first story sale and how
long did you have to submit stories and
get rejections before you broke through
yeah I wanted to be a writer I that was
for me you know that was the thing that
I really cared about because I really
liked to do it from an early age so I
was getting something I was getting
something back
you always know like when a a kid finds
his sweet spot because you don't have to
tell him to practice it isn't practice
you know you're getting something out of
it so I started to write stories and
submit them around the age of probably
twelve
my first admissions and you know I
submitted them to Forrest J Ackerman
oh boy had Famous Monsters of Filmland
and he had other magazines there was a
magazine called spaceman I think and I
got to see 4e before he died and he had
saved some of those early submissions so
and they're written on a you know old
royal typewriter that I had so I started
to send stories out and and I pounded a
nail into the wall of my bedroom and
when I got the rejection slips back I
would put them on that nail and by the
time that I was 16 or 17 years old the
nail tore free from the plaster so I
just got a bigger nail and then when I
was 19 I sold a story to Starling
mystery stories it was called the glass
floor and they paid me like I think 35
bucks that's my first sale there's a lot
of money back then there was a lot of
money and a lot but the thing is like
can I can I tell another story
I I sold two stories to those Robert
loud news magazine starlings mystery
stories I remember them there was
another one tales of horror and suspense
or something they were small checks so
when I was a senior in high school in
college rather I wrote for the
campus newspaper and one of the big
attractions was they had all these
typewriters and my typewriter in the
place the apartment where I live
basically sucked a bird so they had
these typewriters and just before I
graduated I had an idea I'd worked the
summer before in a woman mill and when
fourth of July week came along the
foreman said we're going to shut down
the mill for a week now you have your
choice either you can take the week off
without pay or you can join this Creek
cleaning crew we're gonna go down and
we're gonna clean the basement and the
sub-basement where nobody's bother to
clean anything out for years so I took
the week off and when I came back this
guy I worked with in the in the dye
house said oh man
Steve you should have been there it was
it was a far-out they gave us hoses and
we went down there were no rats
everywhere man they were jumping out
they were his biggest cats and we washed
him down the gummies and you know into
the Androscoggin River so I was thinking
about this and I said I'm gonna write a
story but in my story is going to be
even bigger rats and they will have
mutated down there in the dark they're
gonna be as big as cats are gonna be as
big as dogs and so that story was called
graveyard shift because that's when they
were doing it and
and so I was working on this story and
one of my friends came in Mac came in
and he said what are you doing Steve and
I said well I'm writing a story about
giant rats under a mill and this
cleaning crew is kind of besieged by
these rats and driven backward he said
man that's great he said what you've got
to do is like one of these guys goes
crazy and he's running around he's
ripping rats heads off you know I'm
flinging the bodies beside and
everything and and I thought to myself
it's good but it's not literary okay it
doesn't have that sort of like feeling
John Cheever John Updike kind of feeling
him so what I did instead of that was
cuz he was on the right track he just
didn't he wasn't shooting high enough so
in my story one of the guys is bitten by
rats all over his legs and he screams
and while his mouth is open to scream a
rat climbs into his mouth and I just
wanted to try and you know do it as
elegantly as possible so so you can feel
the rats fur on the roof of his mouth
and the legs scrabbling it his chin and
his throat as the rat grabs hold of the
guy's tongue and rips it out of his
mouth and I sold that story for 200
bucks
okay which is more than 35 pardon me
is more than 35 it was more than 30 you
were moving up in the world that was too
Cavalier magazine and I sold a bunch of
others to those I got married the next
year and and we had a little girl Naomi
and when she got the ear infections my
my wife would say hurry up think of a
monster
[Laughter]